well the spread of the corona virus has
taken its toll on markets around the
world trillions of pounds has been wiped
off the value of shares in recent days
oil prices are downed by around a third
that's the biggest fall in almost 30
years well our business presenter in
King is live from the city inking what
is happening on the markets hello Adam
yes I join you from the trading floor at
peal Hunt City stock brokers were the
footsie 100 opened an hour ago the
footsie has fallen very very sharply by
8 percent at one point and the footsie I
can tell you is now officially in bear
market territory haven't fallen by more
than 20 percent since its most recent
peak in February now the real driver for
all this Adam is the oil price that's
been behind this latest lurch downwards
on Friday afternoon the Saudi Arabians
and their allies in OPEC failed to reach
production cut agreement with Russia
they've been looking for the Russians to
trim their output by around half a
million barrels a day the Russian said
they weren't going to play ball the
reason for that production cut was that
they wanted to bring supplies into into
balance with demand which is obviously
fallen off post the corona virus
outbreak the Russians as I say wouldn't
play ball so over the weekend the Saudis
have effectively declared a trade war on
the Russians they've said that they're
going to up production as a result
you've seen this really historic fall in
oil prices crude dropping by 30 percent
over the weekend $11 a barrel or so and
Brent crude I mean that is the biggest
one-day fall since the first Gulf War
back in 1991 the word crash is often
overused but I don't think it's an over
exaggeration on this particular occasion
to say that the price of all has
absolutely crashed now that particularly
hurts the footsie 100 because it's very
heavy in resources stocks there likes a
Royal Dutch Shell and BP
respectively the 1st and 5th biggest
companies on the footsie 100 well both
of those came off by more than 20% at
the open they stabilized during the last
hour or so but both of those stocks very
very important bellwethers held by
millions of shareholders around the
world by almost every index track of
funds will those of fallen but they're
around about 17 to 18 percent lower
right
now the other really dramatic news that
I have to bring you Adam is what's been
going on in the gilt market now you've
obviously seen a big dash towards
sovereign debt bonds in recent days and
that has depressed the yield to the
yield falls when the price rises and you
saw on Friday afternoon for example on
Wall Street US Treasuries really the
yield on those really really dropping
overnight you've seen that yield on
30-year US Treasuries the long bond
which is a very key financial instrument
that's gone below 1% for the first time
ever this morning more dramatically that
not for the UK UK government bonds gilts
you've seen the yield on 2-year gilts go
negative for the first time ever in
other words borrowers are actually
paying the UK government for the right
to lend a mother to lend money to it now
this is something we've seen in the
eurozone over the years for example with
German government bonds you've seen
those trading on negative yields this
has never happened with the UK before
say very very dramatic moment all sorts
of implications Adam for government
borrowing given him that rishis soon at
the new chancellor is being urged in
some quarters to increase government
borrowing turn on the spending taps and
the gilt market essentially certainly on
the 2-year level is giving him every
opportunity to do that but I mean the
broad picture Adam is it's absolute
carnage you're seeing that as I say big
big drops in some of the oil prices the
likes of International Airlines Group
the owner of British Airways that's been
smacked by another 8% today as well so
really ugly picture right across the
piece and the irony in King is that
normally a low oil price and low
interest rates would be a stimulus for
industry yes that's absolutely right out
of normally a higher or price is seen as
a tax on growth but in this particular
instance you've got a fairly toxic
combination because the oil price has
got two factors depressing that one is
lower demand as a result of coronavirus
and the other is higher supply with the
Saudis turning on the spending taps this
this is going to have all sorts of
knock-on effects everywhere Adam you're
going to see for example I think some of
the big US shale producers they're going
to come under pressure a lot of those
have issued a lot of debt as in the junk
bond market you can see that that coming
under pressure so the knock on the
we'll be right across all sorts of
financial assets classes but to your
point is very interesting actually in
this regard to look at what happened in
Japan overnight now the Nikkei the main
Japanese stock index fell by some 5%
Japan is a very very big oil consumer a
big oil importer other things being
equal you would assume that this would
do this would be very good for the
Japanese economy potentially offer some
stimulus what seems to have happened is
that there's been a rush into the
Japanese yen now the yen is obviously
seen as a bit of a safe haven at times
like this a higher yen means that it's
more expensive for Japanese exporters to
export their goods and accordingly
that's why you've seen the Nikkei
selling off you're seeing all sorts of
asset classes coming under some very
unusual pricing movements indeed